If you are a migrant,
listen because this interests you.
The government has just informed
that at the beginning of 2024
the immigration regulations will be reformed
to simplify procedures and to inflate
and improve protection
of migrants' rights.
Incorporating 1 Community directive,
you can request 1 residence,
1 residence and work permit
within a maximum period of 90 days.
Therefore,
equal treatment will be ensured.
among migrants
requesting
this residence and work permit
with eh the Spaniards
and are to be protected against labor exploitation.
Therefore,
what will be guaranteed are
the guarantees of protection
against labor exploitation,
the improvement of residents' rights
long-lasting
and their families.
What did you think of this 2024 reform?
of the law on foreigners?
Leave it in the comments!